two aspects of story jumped out of me
and you told me there's something
amazing but you wouldn't tell me what it
was but a month or two ago remember the
conversation yeah and he told me that
there was something related to what was
going on production of the car in sales
tell me what your story sort of brakes
well you know I mean the model acid come
out in 2012 rate I affair great reviews
already had been names for the Motor
Trend Car of the Year and you had all
these early adopters they came in and
bought the car and then what sort of
started to happen is that word of mouth
wasn't that great I mean it had some
glitches with the tour handles the
windshield wipers things like that on
the forums people were giving it a hard
time and there were all these customers
in line that had they'd bought a spot in
line to buy a Tesla and they weren't
following through with actual we got a
timeline up of the screen I want to go
through that tonight real quick because
the timeline really starts to tell this
story right of what you're describing so
the first thing that happens at the time
line that goes on sale in the middle of
the year November twins born to a friend
car of the year and everyone's like
Tesla's great that's great there were
but the sales weren't happening people
put the money down but it was a fully
fund Abul deposit as I recall and the
complaints happen a cars cars start to
catch on fire they jack the price and he
goes every one of the companies says
we're in a crisis I don't care what you
think you do here your job is delivering
cars yeah I mean as I was told the story
you know he some of the executives are
kind of held the severity of the
situation from him a little bit and then
you know they come to him they say look
I mean we're on a crisis state and he
takes people in HR and finance and
engineering and he says get on the phone
your job from now on is calling these
customers and turning the pre-orders
into sales and about that word-of-mouth
yeah you're telling me that everyone's
the company was finding out the word of
mouth was bad well yeah yet and yet in
earnings conference call
investors asked specifically about that
because you could see it in the online
forums you could see it if you talk to
people said some people love their
Tesla's other people had some issues
with them and and so let me let me read
you what he said of the conference is
early opted to be on the conference call
he says I'm the conference called to
investors the owners of the company he
says there's nothing better than
word-of-mouth which has really been
fantastic it wasn't fantastic
well yeah it's funny I mean because you
did have Motor Trend you had
these people who fell in love with Tesla
it's sort of like Apple it has that
cultish kind of thing and then so you
have that group of people that are sort
of celebrating the car then you had
another group of people who you know had
paid $100,000 for a car and expected
everything to be you know understandably
perfect and and started to grumble and I
think I think that started to catch up
with the company so among the other
things that were differing from what he
was telling investors and indeed in like
the conference call where you're
required to like tell the truth for
example the revival was kind of
miraculous for this company that among
the things that started to happen and I
even reading a story I didn't quite
understand what happened that they shut
down the factory well first let's read
this quote if we don't deliver these
cars we are effed so I don't care what
your jobs you were doing your new job is
delivering car yeah but but then this
miraculous revival happens in spring of
2013 where he shuts down the factory
which nobody knew happened he certainly
didn't tell investors he was shutting
down the factory they offered to sell
the company for six billion dollars and
all of a sudden there was a turnaround
well you know you'd gone to Larry Page
just in case with this rescue plan and
said look if we don't pick up sales
will you buy Tesla and they had the San
shake deal to do that then you know he
puts all these workers in the selling
cars non-stop and is you know as I
understand it and the timeline does seem
to work out on this in the span of about
two weeks
Tesla must have sold you know thousands
of cars ending up in that first
profitable quarter because you'll
remember that quarter was a surprise to
even by Elon optimistic standards that
was a blowout quarter so and the reason
to me that he said deliver cars rather
than sell cars is because the sales was
already happening but the deliveries
were not being accepted and until the
delivery happens they can't call it sold
at the same time they started delivering
cars if the customer would come to the
factory yeah that meant they could
recognize the revenue more quickly yeah
although they didn't have to move a car
to a person to move a person to a
building no it's true well a there's
part of this is you know I mean Nealon
plays those high risk high stakes game I
mean you can see this went right down to
the wire he sort of rolled the dice on
this one and it actually came out in
Tesla's favor but we could be talking
about Tesla as a division of
Google just as easily and it you know
interesting also when he talks about
reservations in that same conference
call where he didn't let on that there
were any problems but he didn't tell the
investors the factory was shut he also
said that things were fine in terms of
reservations because I know that a lot
of investors had figured this out and
they were putting these questions too
specifically in this forum so that he
would try to tell the truth he said that
let me read what he said about early
demand he said quote we have enough for
reservations right now to fill out the
year literally we could say goodbye to
every store every sales person and still
meet our twenty thousand car target
you're saying that wasn't true he was
not only telling every sales person they
had to get cars delivered but they had
to tell every HR person and every
factory worker and every person the name
the more help not well I mean it is sort
of like you say that's a linguistic game
of sorts I mean there's the reservations
there's the pre-orders of people who are
standing in line and I think that number
was huge and then converting that to the
sales was the the tricky part I